plein à l'assemblée nationale une large
majorité de députés a voté la
proposition de loi socialiste prévoyant
la distribution de la pilule du
lendemain en milieu scolaire et en cas
d'urgence le gouvernement a soutenu
cette proposition avec un objectif faire
reculer la fréquence des grossesses non
désirées chez les jeunes adolescentes
analyse dorothée cocheur 1967 les femmes
obtiennent le droit à la contraception
c'est une victoire mais à l'assemblée
nationale on s'entoure de précautions
la pilule a des effets secondaires ils
ne sont pas encore bien connus
elle doit être délivrée sur ordonnance
et avec suivi médical
c'est ce qu'impose la loi neuwirth et
c'était nécessaire parce que à l'époque
les pilules étaient lourdement dosée et
on savait que ça posait des problèmes
pour la série phone est sûr que les
femmes n'auraient pas de problèmes
vasculaires de problèmes de santé
différent parce que les hormones pesé
lourd
aujourd'hui les pilules ne sont plus un
risque pour la santé mais la loi n'a pas
évolué interdisant aux infirmières
scolaires de prescrire la pilule du
lendemain aux adolescentes et c'est sur
ce plan que l'assemblée nationale a
statué aujourd'hui
dorénavant les médicaments ayant pour
but la contraception d'urgence ne sont
plus soumis à prescription obligatoire
de plus ils peuvent être prescrits et
délivré par les infirmières scolaires
aux mineurs délirant garder le secret
pour le gouvernement ce nouvel article
doit pouvoir faire reculer le nombre de
grossesses non désirées chez les
adolescentes elles sont dignes de chaque
année